what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation it's time to get jacked up as you reach
for that like button because guess what we
are watching Reacher episode 5 today and a fun
question for our audience which chemistry do you
prefer the one with Reacher and Rosco or Reacher
and Dixon leave it in the comments hit women
against each other fight fight it out John are
you excited so excited G I'm ready to Swan Dive
into this episode that's what I like to hear my
friend also subscribe and click that notification
to the noi when our reaction for the episode and
the new year is up also thank you to prepper for
helping us setting down these highlights you sexy
people you people also thank you to all who have
joined us at our patreon page helping us to have
a massively successful lucrative Year my God we
have bought five houses thanks to our patrons and
now you can help us buy a sixth when you check us
out on patreon becoming a super sexy reject so we
get the full length ratch and watchalong where
you sync up with your own copy of Reacher John
and I also cover several things exclusive there
with highlights and watch alongs included John
are you ready to get jacked up I'm reaching for
a pun that means yes I am that's what I like to
hear Snowman hey a very special
holiday episode of Reacher Jack
reach Frost I'll give it to you I'll give it
you oh oh [__] wow boy panda pal Lindsay the
monkey they're all packed grab the burner phone
no contact with anyone not your parents and
definitely not your sister she puts everything
on Facebook she's a pain in the ass that sister
1 to 10 how bad is this I'm not going to come
after you we're just playing a safe belts and
suspenders belts and suspenders for you guys
four how about you oh we're dealing with some
pretty bad guys you got the big guy we'll be
fine he'll be over in a couple of days promise
the kids I think have this covered this could be
your life Jack this yeah you could have this
with Dixon a stressed out wife someone asked
me back in the day where I thought you'd wind
up I'd have predicted a slow death from garia
and a half dozen girlfriends fighting over an 04
Miata that's my life it's my Miata NE and Dixon
just got to the Denver plant maybe they get a
hold of those missiles and your family won't
have to be gone long you know I learned about
this odonald guy throughout this whole show
he was a bachelor a player but he settled
down that's why I don't trust him G it's a
Roose okay try hit and reach her like that break
that kid's bones Jack yeah the dcma was here a
month ago yeah now we're back we're the cold
source of government oversight now we if you
please your foran that's a really cool center
frame act like you're supposed to be there and
carry a clipboard dud I I get more clipboards
whoa interesting cut infiltrate so many places
never seen a cut like that it goes from Center
to like diagonal down right you never wore heels
nope not even do a school dance never went
one when I wasn't studying or taking care
of my dad I have to work what about when you
were a hooker yeah nobody told me about this
wouldn't be a surprised inspection if we called
the head that's how we have a hard time finding
out what's going on with chocolate because they
often get a heads up that there's going to be
an inspection there so they can hide the child
labor at Little Wing shoulder fired launchers
and missiles order and delivery schedules 10
minutes ago that's the delivery schedule the
whole lot just went out the door all 650 of them
650 that's the number the number if someone had
called me first damn I'd held them for you
should have anticipated the this Colorado is
beautiful it really looks like this guys yeah now
Jack's going to flip the truck over an Asian guy
he must be a stunt man they hired yes there
will be a martial arts sequence any minute
now you need an extra set of hands what I need is
your truck yeah buddy now cut off
his hands and take them with you
oh man that's mean that truck was being
so nice too whoa yeah he just stopped
to help them and everything they relied
on the willingness of a truck driver who
is going to stop and be like you need an
extra hand yeah the Brotherhood of truck
drivers whoa weapons of mass destruction GPS
tracker did the job your Associates a new age
came through they might be upset I killed the
driver though they won't care as long as they
get paid never underestimate the power of greed
greed is good switch the trailers and get on the
road meet you in New York all this traveling
from Denver to New York so the Aron mikos we
were chasing down in Denver that was mmud yeah
we've been calling him am never been caught no
photos I'm not even sure what nationality he is
just take a guess but the little bit we know of
him he can supposedly pass for Central American
Italian Greek Middle Eastern he's a ghost those
are what people often think I am hey hey you
could be am first popped up on our radar 6 years
ago terrorist cell caught trying to acquire tanks
of experimental nerve gas we scooped up the whole
lot all of them except Mahmud yeah this buy was
supposed to happen with bear bonds the US Treasury
stopped issuing those in the 80s some countries
still use them uhoh someone as cautious as am
would use bear bonds if issued in large enough
amounts you can carry an untraceable fortune
in a briefcase 65 Million worth got get some
you hold a bear bondus like carrying a million
doll Bill the bearer owns it so no way am lets
anyone deliver payment but him that's where he's
vulnerable just like your brother oh way to make
him uncomfortable back when we worked the case I
asked Joe some questions of the financial side of
things said the same thing you just did am will
be the delivery boy okay sad Jack C so fast Sad
Sack Jack Sad Sack Creer I passed the mantle on
to you thank you killing these puns man am and
everyone working with him will be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law bring me the
Arctic Monkeys un must we kill them all firsto
you're in a government office dog love how they
were like oh what do we say to [Music] that o lot
of these Center framing shots are so well done
it's a lot of Center Framing and lower diagonal
good symmetry 18 wheelers can't go that fast on
these roads a decent shot at catching them yeah
especially if they come to a stop uh bo be careful
neon yes neelon dixley the guys who are going to
tell us the truck broke down and they had to
call another one to come pick up the trailer
but no way a second truck got here before us nope
nope nope this is hijacking this may potentially
sound racist but I feel like this ASI guy is
going to do some crazy martial arts let's find
out just do one roundhouse kick bring out your
nunchucks I'm Asian guys I could say it I take
it back oh there's like that ominous snow
Thriller vibe to this like the Snowman with
Michael fast Bender yeah but with Jack it's cool
the steam from the car Blends in with the fog of
the snow and their hot breath breath on the cold
wind we really messed this car up they're in the
trunk they are in the trun D yeah you'd have
access inside look how scared this guy is he
knows you don't mess with the one1 oh [__] oh
damn goly damn you ladies are hot they got them
all over got in the butt I'll call the cops
Anonymous do we favor grabb the Manifest we
need the license play it off of bit it's not
a private road well a new age truck with all
650 missiles in it was hijacked ow it looks like
Swan's still working for new age according to the
bill of lading Swan personally signed off on the
shipment before he left the factory Swan what are
you doing it's a digital thumbprint then they
forced him new age New York has Iris scanners
on the doors Thum print locks on the computers
there's no way that anyone could force Tony Swan
through that Maze of Biometrics without causing
a huge seat new age New York New Age New York
New Age New York the only way that wouldn't
worry about a Ruckus is if all thousand plus
employees were in on this thing and the OD of
a conspiracy that vast or minimal believe all
conspiracy theories I know you want to believe
Swan's clean boss we all do but things look the
way they look you messed up Jack if you never
recruited him and you if you didn't make a
terrible judge of character you wouldn't be in
this position right now Way It Go Jack this is
your fault I Blame You Jack all on you man and
his Hendrick's taste [Music] going for a walk
he seems so sad this episode no D Jack more like
Jack Griefer oh gee see I knew there was a reason
I three to four weeks ago good how' you like
to be jamed into a fox what is a giant mother
we'll be whatever price you're paying now our
supplier can get you all the eight you can move
from an overseas Source it's in no position
to negotiate terms I do H and pump in that
order it's pure Kool-Aid okay the alkaline
level on the H is great bust them lean on
them they give up their Source we bust them
then we all get bumed more fruit s in our
chest more dollar signs on our paychecks bro
give me that fruit salad why would they add
dollar signs it's more paycheck shut up frony
kids cut a point mod well you only need $1 son
yeah breed is a theme yeah which one of y'all
is taking payments [Music] door Dash guys in
on it that 105 sounds like you're was my time
damn dude you have another brick as pure as
that for 105 seem better [__] I got a list of
other buyers Swan I came to you I know you uhoh
no idea I know we've met before what can you
do for me 100 take it or leave it O Come got
it you're the guy I sold my guitar to a while
back what no you got me mixed up with somebody
else Craigslist dude you bought my acoustic
I recognize your username we going to eat and
discuss old times or we going to make a deal you
[__] don't want this stuff we got other places
we can sell it shoot this guy he plays guitar yeah
we're all keyboardists here wait a minute when
this guy bought it he was in an army cop uniform
oh God here it is well that's a setback setback
Reacher oh my god wow my God that
thrust woo oh that's why he trusts
him because Swan took a bullet
for him bullet miss your heart
but shatter my collar bone not going to
be playing that guitar for a while every
cloud hey who don't you mess with the teamsters
no the also them 110 he's losing blood it's 110
special investigators what's the 110 the
same thing they're the oneth and they're
the special investigator keep all this in
the reaction prepper yeah I mean it let me
pull up the Wikipedia on the 110th here the
senator has a proposition for you get in no
because he didn't ask nicely heart what's
a magic word Jack pleaser please get in
the vehicle damn it really does work when
you say please the Little Wing chips will
be ready to install on the missiles by the
time you get here and Mr Swan's Associates
will be taken care of their plan's already
in motion excellent put my best people on it
kingck is a rert Patrick kind of look like a evil
baby he does now yeah right his face he's got like
a baby evil baby face assume you use this location
cuz it's one of the few spots in DC where you can
meet without prying eyes or surveillance bugs
MH it's why I got myself appointed to the zoos
board imagine Boyd's embarrassment when he he
learned that the people he revealed our secrets
to weren't FBI agents in the first place of course
security videos showed you entering the precinct
and facial recognition software matched you to
a military ID God damn AI seems like after you
retired you kind of fell off the face of the
earth except for this incident a couple years
ago in Mar grave Georgia Mar grave I know it
was you and margrave Mr rer I want you to do
the same thing for the situation we have here o
the mil military and civilian aircraft could be
in danger due to little wi now I can only assume
that means the terrorists are interested in the
attack working hard to obtain it who do you trust
we learned that your old units back together don't
look so shocked Mr reer I'm us Congressman I get
things done I'm shocked because a US Congressman
got everything done yep yep it's truly a work
of fiction this Show's political now people who
want this Weaponry can never be allowed to have
it because if anyone knew you were involved in
the Shady dealings that created Little Wing in
the first place you'd be indicted give rid the
bad guys keep my hands clean Washington we call
that a win-win two birds one Reacher I did what
I did to give our side the tools they need to
defend democracy I just avoided the typical red
tape that does nothing but cause the delays that
cost lives this guy's a pain in the ass I don't
want innocent people to die because of it I'm a
political animal I'm not a monster Mr eer we're
in a zoo oh they're in the political sub cont
and the meanings and the themes and this you like
to upset the apple cart I'm prepared to give you
whatever you need to Aid you in that endeavor and
when you're done no one will be able to prove that
you were ever near those apples in the first place
woo get all the resources of the reptile house on
your disposal then you can disappear again no one
will go looking for you or your friends but does
he want to be alone but if no one's looking for
me how will I know I'm real I mean seems like a
reasonably good offer or an reasonably good cover
coroner finally released Cron's body funeral's
tomorrow whoa we got to go back to New York all
right shootout oh yeah also have a shootout at the
funeral how cool would that be yeah I've always
wanted to be at a shootout at a funeral mhm jump
onto the coffin you know use it as cover yeah you
have any leads as to where the real misses went
Colorado State Police found the truck in a field
outside Denver it's empty based on the tracks
in the dirt they think a private plane flew the
weapons out overnight Wow since 11 they've kept
a pretty close watch on New York's skies I were
him I fly him into some small air in Pennsylvania
maybe New Hampshire then drive the weapons into
New York to load them up with little wing software
are U am I love how they're at this funeral and
they're doing nothing to reflect on just talking
about the cas that's what you do at cinematic
funerals reer seeing this [__] I'm sorry
for your loss rest rest in peace all right
my nephews have the same one a it's a great toy
we play with it all the time when I was a kid I
had Aquaman hey I thought it was so cool how he
could talk to fish too bad it's going to flop
I want you to have this too hey s Jerome he's
the patron s of kids whose moms and dads go to
heaven s Jerome I don't ever want to be alone want
you to say the forever every night and I'll hope
keep you that close damn this gu friends with the
kid the dead I don't know he's like looking after
this kid awfully close maybe it's just because
he's invested in the case you know why are you
giving toys to my dead friend son cozy up to the
kid score points with Mom you see a grieving Widow
and think easy target are you kidding me right
now why' a biker gang take a run at me in Boston
last night cuz you're an [__] or maybe it's cuz
you're the only person I told we were going there
ass Reacher you know why I was talking to Mikey I
know what it is to look out the window every night
and pray that the next set of headlights coming
down the street is your father's car even though
you know it'll never happen yep and I was talking
about you not your father I'm talking about it my
father was a cop a good one and he refused to be
on the take and they killed him for it damn dude
guys you're causing a scene will you call me dirty
one more time and I don't care if we're standing
in front of the Statue of the holy mother I will
give you that beating that I owe you right here
I'll take that fight anytime you want and two I
didn't know that about your father I was running
those security names from new age or former NYPD
or from the third precin whoa boss Langston and
a few other guys they were on Investigation by
IIA they took early retirement and the charges
went away then they all got cushy jobs at New Age
and they hired all their P they on the take take
you need work with this whole team of bad cops
everybody except your buddy Swan but he's the
only one that has military experience to know what
type of weapons terrorists want so oh all cops all
bad all from the same Precinct you interview
any of them Gooden you turned their office
into a drive-thru they went to the ground Swan's
like a son yeah he's so defensive for him stand
by very graceful sequence ready a fire
oh little guy oh get down whoa whoa what
the damn how' you spot him shoot it
at the funeral yes we got it we got
it oo o the Tombstones do make for great
cover oh this is a really cool scene yeah
buddy good way for the cops can't let let
them get away as soon as they hear
sirens they scatter I'll draw their
fire you take them out negative we
can do this take your clothes off
rer oh yeah Jack is like the guy in every video
game who's like huge and slow but has like all
the
this the guy with all the strength
and guns good cinematic music whoa
come on Jack they must have shot this at
a real graveyard ceter absolutely every
one of the people buried here is an actor so
they would have wanted this I want to buy a
BMW hey all Let's go Team
Up you shoot at a funeral
AET I saw you protect Angel and Mikey so
I guess you're playing a square you got a
rat in your house still that's for sure no
no time for this guys you both got a rat R
to deal with get this terrified sniper yeah
pedal on the right let me do my [Music] job
how just never gets along with lead
detectives I know you climb out of my
ass ass Reacher this is all really
well done intense sweeping high
speed Pursuit jeez dude I would not
be able to concentrate with you as
a passenger uh Jack seat driver dad
not bad at all not bad at all sneaky
sneaky oh yeah don't shoot I'm done okay I'm done
sh in the legs at least you're under arrest [__]
these guys took a run at us in broad daylight at
a crowded funeral means this thing's coming to a
head fast yeah he lawyers up and doesn't talk
until it's too late in a ter has 650 chances
to take down a commercial airliner so what do
you want me to do play a little dirty look the
other way oh dude no oh my God by not telling me
everything you know you're protecting the people
who killed my friends I'm not going to waste my
time with enhanced interrogation techniques I'm
just going to squeeze the life out of you so if it
any best reaction Langston wouldn't give you all
the cash up front where you supposed to meet him
to get the rest of the money an abandoned building
is some shitty neighborhood and queens give it
the address oh but I don't know any Langston and
who hired you I'm SW guy called Swan no jaon and
odonnell are in position Russo's down the street
all Lexus are covered Swan's going to put a bullet
in raer Richer's going to be like Swan's in a city
he's he's being leveraged by somebody he's been
forced to do this he's brainwashed we'll cut you
loose you get to keep the cash understood yeah man
whatever keep this in your pocket so we can listen
in you try anything we come in hot and you die
with the rest of them get going stupid keep it
simple stupid he's K so goddamn aggressive I love
it you idiot somean went to work for new age it's
all a chance to make the kind of money he always
dreamed of and took it he was hanging out with
franzy and being in the same city and all slipped
and said something that made France supicious oh
boy try to get France in on it figure with a wife
and kid he'd need the money too this building GNA
blow up I think it probably is if Swan's really
in that building I'm gonna do the same thing
I did to that guy wrap my hand around his neck
and squeeze the truth out of him swan song hello
anyone I completed the
job boy oh boy oh boy Swan just going to
be standing in the middle of it all yeah
just stare bearing down re Sunshine
villain now warped Freddy Krueger
guy o God what a note to end on too I don't
know this Swan guy but it's about to be his
Swan's song Oh yes sir you know what I'm
saying I do know what you're saying this
is the end of swan you're about to be gone
Swan your time is dawn dark is a [__] you
did it you did it it's okay it's okay I'm
here for you yeah that's what I want wanted
you to be there for me I didn't want to
say it myself I'm your neie me and my
Cal anyway yeah I really like this episode uh it
was a really good one per they're setting up the
personal Stakes we were o Donal and his family so
that way we saw that there's something to lose for
odonnell at the beginning here that if you were
to die I I do think one of them has they're still
they're still pretty much a team of Avengers and I
think we need to get one of them severely injured
on the brink of death okay I do think we need to
get there however I still thought this episode
was fun engaging I'm really into the whole it's
weird like we don't really see Swan like only in
flashbacks yeah and because we see how much it
affects Jack it makes me really want that conf
I I'm I'm craving that confrontation definitely
I really want that and the show is doing a great
job at pulling that out of me like oh I'm seeding
for that man I'm craving it I'm craving I'm like
at a buffet and I'm like what do I want all I see
is this swan dish that I want and it's that that
I don't care about the potatoes this metaphor is
going terribly guys it's like when you're at the
when they wrap your food food up and they make
the swan out of it with the foil yeah we need to
move on from the swan metaphor Swan metaphors done
check check and um the and the and you know like
a reminder of how like all of Reacher's family is
gone and like this is essentially his last living
family yeah you know so he'll do whatever he can
to protect them and that's why this is so personal
for him so that that that uh the real showdown
at the funeral to me in a lot of ways because
I'm deep as [__] is the confrontation between
him and bald New York cop car Russo I think his
name Russo yeah uh when they're when they're
arguing with each other I love them together
yeah they have a great back and forth because it
does remind you a little bit of um black Boston
cop Finley yeah yeah not white Southern Girl blond
cop uh yeah yes uh uh oh goodness I know her name
uh John I've known all their names and you can't
pull this one I've known all their names oh it'll
I've been setting you having a blank come on John
uh okay Finlay and uh Rosco there you go yeah yeah
anyway you put me on the spot and then my brain
cleared out oh no yeah so uh still no Cameo from
her no no at the very endend she'll come back
pregnant with reach yeah we're starting a team
a family a family Reacher yes oh I love it oh
my God uh but the yeah that that whole funeral
scene I thought was uh really strong the way
they paid the military tribute seemed very well
orchestrated and then to go like I just thought
it was a really solid sequence of showing up at
the funeral them deliberating over you know what
do they what what is the next plan of action here
what could really be going down you know Reacher
dialogue and then uh the confrontation with the
cop after he's confronting then it was a great
way to pull out some personal stuff with the
characters that moment saying goodbye solemnly
then leading to a great shootout that kind of
reminds me of like a seet from way of the gun
leading to a cool car chase to an epic like the
last like 15 to 20 minutes of this I thought
was just perfectly executed yeah I thought it
was really really really well executed um it was
like a strong action political thriller show uh in
that moment and just seeing how Reacher is just
getting pushed to the brink of like his his uh
he's becoming so impatient and uh I love it I love
it and because he has to keep agitated he just has
to keep that suit on in the whole time that same
smelly stinky suit Colorado New York funeral CH
way more once he takes the suit off it's cutting
off the circulation to his head realiz it's just
he just needs a change of clothes yeah of course
anyway John what do you think of Robert Patrick's
role oh he's great man the boss baby is killing
uh I I I mean you know Robert Patrick is so far
in this show he's he's mainly he's on the phone
the presence of Robert Patrick being on the phone
swearing at people I like him and I'm excited for
the eventual Showdown or whatever confrontation
comes with him but for it's you know like watching
the especially the past couple of episodes have
been really nice because uh as I was hoping the
season has grown and I have gotten more and more
tuned to what it's doing this time around I really
like all that stuff and uh and Robert Patrick is
maybe the one element that still feels a bit
detached from the Flesh of everything else uh
because when he shows up it does seem like we're
mainly just having Robert Patrick show up and and
be intense but also I get the sense and stressed
intense and stressed and I get the sense that and
not in a not to like slight the performance of the
writing but like in context of the story I get the
sense that this is going to be a guy who probably
ain't [__] at the end of the day and is probably
going to go down pretty easy uh so I'm curious to
see how they build his formidability by the end
of the season because it seems like am is the guy
on that side of things who's like the real threat
and now we have Swan at least looking to be pretty
dang guilty in all of this and hey maybe they'll
still pull a Twist on us where it's like oh man
I had to go so deep under cover and I had to let
so many things happen not to blow my cover you
know there's all sorts of stuff uh I know because
I have been an undercover cop for many years of
course you know you got to let certain things play
out you can't just bust in immediately and start
taking people down because they're bigger fish
I know you've been in unrecovered cop for blind
wave this entire time that's right man people ask
me if I am that guy I am that guy he is that guy
for blind W he is that othery wh anyway uh yeah
I've been very much uh just yeah the the mve mood
of this really gripped me and like you said the
snow and the air and that feeling of yeah like
an insomnia or one of those like snow-based uh
this was the most atmospheric episode absolutely
I think out of every EP this all that's all I've
been craving I've haven't been craving like the
Southern Gothic grit of season 1 I've just been
wanting a specific flavor and I think I think this
episode really provided that like oh you really
feel the cold yeah you really and as it's getting
colder for them physically the emotional turmoil
is also withering away throughout them yeah and
you feel like the the reer gets colder Jack gets
colder he's going to need a jacket to warm down
how cold he's get yeah he's going to need one of
those fleece jackets Jack Reacher the Sheep uh
yeah the the wool kind of call you know you know
what I mean yeah Lion's man that's exactly it he's
going to skin a lion where it's man he's going to
go back crav the hunter by the end of this yeah
craving the reacher uh I like that scene when they
go into the gorilla house or whatever that was and
they have the meeting with the politician guy and
he fun fact is a deleted scene where he fought a
gorilla oh or did Allen richson just pick a fight
with a gorilla and if no both it might have I
think they tried using it as footage but then
they real keep rolling on this don't don't stop
rolling on I think he's winning I think I think
this gorilla is about to go extinct okay Alan
Rich's now he he's on all fours and he's he's
crawling into the cave and he's claiming dominance
over the rest of the girl he's beating his chest
and he's making all these strange noises and all
the gorillas are gathering around him thinks he's
a gorilla who's going to pull Alan out of there
does anybody speak sign language what do we got
Alan has officially murdered our ad yeah he
directs the show now just tells people where
to point the camera and everybody else just yes
sir Mr Jack Mr Mr Rich whatever you want me to
call you it's fine no eye contact I would pay
good money for I would pay good money to watch
a gorilla versus Alan mer to watch him reain
dominion over a not just gorillas but gorillas
in a zoo yeah watch him lift a gorilla above
his head before he drops it down on his knee
Bane style your spirit or your body just an a loin
cloth living at the zoo yes a loin cloth he would
look good he would look really good in a Lo Club
he would man so we need someone from IGN just be
like would you play Jesus and be like I would be
interested and then bam we get a whole bunch of
Articles and headlines alen richon interested in
playing Jesus and we get all that fan art of him
in a loin cloth yeah I think it look good and
him with like the long hair too yeah but still
just as buff as he is right now I mean you got
to get a different interpretation we've seen all
kinds of Jesus rules he's got that buff where
you have to just turn your whole body to look
at people why wouldn't you listen to him like
how does guy gets so buff and zero BC you know
that's a good question I don't know you're the
bodybuilder Among Us how and I know how to achieve
that that physique even with all the modern gym
technology we have today I definitely know how
to achieve that you know just eat a 100 chickens
a day never stop benching never stop never stop
benching anyway uh yeah uh am what do you think
about am isn't he great he was here for a minute
yeah we saw him for we got so many villains yeah
we do we need a female villain that way the women
have someone to fight yeah well there was that one
lady from the um New Age company but they already
raided her house know she was kind of like an
annoying you know you need look if when you have
the big finale at the end it's the women fight the
women that's the that's why you have a bad woman
get get at least like an evil female henchman
yeah for for Robert P like evil female henchman
assistant who happens to be great at martial arts
yeah and who never speaks and who has some kind
of eccentric weapon oh yeah yeah yeah and then
like Neely can fight her yeah exactly and then
that' be great right yeah and then Dixon joins
in and they both take her down yeah then it's a
message about girl women working together drive
that home yeah yeah dude that's how you how you
that's how you infuse Progressive feminism into
your show which is what I'm all about especially
when I show forck Reacher man oh yeah you know
Jack Reacher is a feminist look at the team he
assembled there were intersectional there were
women on the team people various ethnicities yeah
people color not very many old people or disabled
people but you know it's the Army and so you know
what can you do unfortunately but with what he's
given Jack is a pretty enlightened cat yeah oh
totally based based Reacher um anyway am was great
I love am was great man him on the phone just Jack
and Russo is my favorite thing like I I I I I love
the team together but uh the moment with Russo and
the kid and and the Widow I thought was great and
him and Jack and and and even though especially
throughout the Chase and everything they're so Odd
Couple Jack is constantly busting his chops like
when they get to that moment and after everything
made about like I'm not dirty you know that that
that moment of convincing where Jack is like look
they're getting desperate and following the book
is going to hurt this investigation in the long
run like that was a pretty compelling beat oh sure
and the way they played that in the acting and and
the framing I thought was nice just him being like
okay turn turn the cheek cuz I trust you you know
and I trust that this is for a good reason and
that whole thing with his dad his dad wouldn't
take any bribes so he got whacked you know like
yeah I mean and Jack and Rose so they honor their
legacies they do they respect where they come from
Legacy no
notes perfect cut print anyway um say John
yeah one thing that I do feel is getting kind
of lost here uh-huh huh it seemed like when
they got to episode two they were like Dixon
Reacher and then they've like had a couple of
conversations and unless there's like a direct
interaction I don't feel like it's something
that's in the air between them okay sexual
attention or nor chemistry nor romance that idea
of like when you get into like a life and death
situation they're not thinking about oh I got
to get back to Reacher oh I got to get back
to Dixon it's sort of just like whenever there
I'm really not sure what it is with them yeah
it feels like a thing that could happen but
isn't necessarily it doesn't have that like
propulsively see portrayed that you can just
be casual friends with benefits I'm waiting to
see what the payoff is of that because uh when
they're when they're at the funeral and stuff
there's like nothing with them you know that's
true I'm not saying there has to be like like
great romance scenes or some [__] making out at
the funeral but it's been like a few episodes of
nothing with them really other than like oh he
sees her in a dress he like damn she look good
yeah and then they all bust his his chops about
that yeah Donald's like wow is that something in
your pants Reaching Forward you know oh hey it's
pennis Jack Jack Jack weener Jack weer Jack we we
grew up P yep we grew up from when we met yep yep
yep we both literally We Are Men We are adults we
made a genitals joke was childish were like it's
so goofy cuz they might do it they might can't
say that can't say that word what would happen
if on the show they they did it like in the last
episode the last frame is them doing it together
just doing it uh I I like I'm torn and I think
I'm you know I'm just sitting here waiting for
the end of the season to come because I'm like
I partly en enjoy because I hate this show I hate
everything about it and all the viewers who tune
in every week to both the show and these reactions
we shouldn't have been middling about the second
or third episode now no one wants to watch our
videos you know anytime I have that feeling
I'm just going to be like I assume I'll like this
later so I love it now uh but uh I mean part of me
is is enjoying the fact that it isn't the point
or it isn't like a major focal aspect however
I I do get what you mean and I am rooting for
something to become of this romance I think the
show is in an unique position because this first
season had such a lovely kind of thing with Rosco
but you also know that we're going to roll out of
town and onto the next thing so you can't well I
can see how Dixon could have a relationship with
him and they could travel around together I just
think that chemistry or whatever they're they hint
at romantically or even sexually is kind of like
completely absent unless they make like a scene
about it you know yeah totally and I mean I I buy
parts of that because they're you know they're
so professional their unit and everything and
they have their group is true you know how to
separate it yeah but at the same time I don't
like whenever like all of us are in the room I
forget about you and terara yes yes we've been
married for so long now being a long-term husband
and wife couple that's right you know we like to
be professional so professional that no one knows
we're even involved with each other sometimes you
guys forget yeah and I'm like wait Tera you can't
be making out with that guy you're married to John
you can't go out on another date you're oh sorry
I'm being professional in public no one will know
this is the best cover possible I mean it is it
is or you're just a Brazen cheater but you know
as long as you don't enjoy any of it then it's a
good cover Merry Christmas Merry Christmas team
I think this video is I think it was that a while
ago leave your best Reacher puns in the comments
yeah
bye all right John pick a name oh goodness who
could it be well you know why don't we go with
Kevin smart why just because I feel like that
would be a smart thing to do here at the very end
of our Patron list for the month I love hearing it
Kevin right now you are our last patron of the day
shout out uh I cannot hear out of my left ear and
my right nose is my right nostril is clogged it's
a real weird ear just nose and throat experience
I'm having right now but I am so happy to be here
with you because when I was outside I bumped into
the Hanukkah bear and oh yeah and I don't know if
you know about the Hanukkah bear but this this
Santa comes through the chimney hanuk be goes
through your trash and hanuk be he I don't know
how he does it but hanuk be goes all worldwide
around and goes through everyone's trash days and
leaves yeah yeah that's that's the thing is like s
24 hours Hanukkah bear has eight days to get it
done so it's kind of a cheat C for the Hanukkah
bear and the Hanukkah bear uh he he done left
you some great things and he but he had to give
it all to you in one day oh and so Kevin smart
what's what did he give him John oh Kevin smart
the first day of Hanukkah bear visits he barfed
up some body parts for you to sort through I mean
those those will come in handy you know and we
are on the verge of an apocalypse did you hear
about Biden and all them building bunkers you
know that means that they're we're on the verge
of Apocalypse pretty soon cannibalism is going
to become a normal thing so there you go El get
uh oh he he got um a PS4 that's great man PS4
they're much more valuable you can bu you get
two PS4s put them together you got ps8 isn't that
magical dude it's so crazy and then you can upload
your Consciousness on yeah see yeah uh oh on the
third day uh oh he he brought you a nice bowl of
Christmas punch somehow that's great man you know
Christmas punch is good to get drunk while you're
sipping on some limbs yes definitely oh and and
then the fourth thing that the Hanukkah bear
brought you is uh uh one of those Smokey the Bear
fire risk signs so that you could always be aware
of when you are a risk to uh you know causing a
fire very true especially in times of cannibalism
you might need to know if there's a fire going
off that way and you need to get your sniper
rifle ready and get ready to hunt down some people
might want to take over your territory but you got
to look after your own yeah and you might want
to use that fire to cook them so if you could you
know like snipe the people as close the fire as
possible this is just practical for planning Amen
to that what else amen eight days John he brought
you oh a new electric toothbrush cuz you know you
got to keep your teeth clean it's always a good
idea I don't need to add on with six yeah six day
uh oh he brought you he he just took a dump on
the driveway you know Hanukkah bear he's eating
a lot of stuff and got avoid that to keep limber
believe it or not that could be a great dessert
for you and your future family and then you you
got to spread it Camp you're going to be a camp
leader you're going to need to spread it out some
people you know put human remains in pies you're
going to have to put bare fees yeah seven Olive
Garden gift card of course yes that uh there will
be the one thriving restaurant in the in the apoc
can Pacos just don't eat the bread sticks they're
not like they used to be no they're made out
of bare feces yes of course they are and uh oh
the last day uh for Hanukkah bear brought you new
trash cans because let's face it the old ones are
going to be wrecked by the time the Hanukkah bear
is done with them it's occupational hazard so yeah
man dude Kevin Smart looks like you are going
to be living the High Life come 2024 else got
their bunkers let's recap uh you I don't remember
what the first thing is you got body parts bared
up body parts uh it's a PS4 uh uh some something
or other an Olive Garden gift card and and some
Tonk some linked logs and a Tonka toy and some
tily winks and a new trash can some real [__]
in there some poop source of [__] all righty
man oh electric toothbrush in there somewhere
yeah yeah yeah Merry Christmas so many good
things and happy Hanukkah love you [Music] bud